hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to a
rather depressing and fear-inducing
episode of reality check
I've got to say of all the topics we've
covered on this show this has not been
one of the cheers to research we all
know games take things like real life
with a rather hefty dollop of salt none
more so than the Fallout franchise my
granny's turn to a life of crime
men can be trees and Matthew Perry's
acting can be so so flat Benny's gonna
show you the tops I hope you're built
sturdy you crazy broad I thought I'd
take a look at just what would happen to
life on Earth
if the events of fallouts great war
actually happened spoilers there's a lot
of death destruction and yeah overall
it's just not good times for anyone okay
so let's take a look at the sheer force
of the nukes that will be dropped
according to the Bible that is the
fallout wikia during the Great War in
2077 most of the nukes dropped by well
everyone had yields of roughly 200 to
750 kilo tons that may not sound like a
lot compared to Megaton class nukes with
a blast equivalent of at least 1 million
tons of TNT but to put it into
perspective the real-life nuclear bombs
dropped on the Japanese cities of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki in world war ii
had yields of 15 and 21 kilo tons
respectively put together those bombs
killed at least 129 thousand people with
some estimates even going as high as 240
9000 while the actual number of nukes
that countries worldwide are housing is
a closely guarded secret the Federation
of American scientists nuclear
information project which uses
information gleaned from public records
and leaks has estimated that there are
around 17,000 nukes in the wild with
over 4000 of these ready to be used at
short notice due to the fact that
billions live in densely populated
cities even a quote-unquote small nuke
would be devastating so if a fallout
great war scenario were to happen even
with these lower yield nukes a lot of
the world's population would cop it
throw in some higher yield ones - yeah
most of us about
but maybe not all with those who
survived the bombs also survived the
wasteland well to know that we have to
understand what the wasteland would
actually be like and as we don't have
one to hand we have to go off scientific
simulations that give us a good idea
about what it will be like thanks to a
team of atmospheric and environmental
scientists in the u.s. we have a pretty
good idea
they run a detailed simulation on a
limited regional nuclear war using a
hundred bombs each roughly the size at
the one dropped on Hiroshima so a 15
kilo time yield the results well asides
from the death of a couple of billion
people even a hundred low-yield bombs
have the power to royally mess up the
planets first off the bombs would
produce around 5 megatons of black
carbon which would gradually float on up
into the atmosphere and spread around
the world this would cause a drop in
surface temperature and an intense
heating of the stratosphere which is one
of the major layers of our atmosphere
this then causes a nuclear winter earth
will be 1.5 degrees centigrade colder
which is colder than it's been for the
past thousand years it'll be nigh on
impossible to grow crops as they'll be
9% less rainfall and devastating cold in
fact crop growing season will be reduced
by 10 days to just 40 the ozone layer
will be about 25 to 50 percent thinner
and so we won't be as protected from the
sun's UV rays meaning that any survivors
will be incredibly likely to get sunburn
and skin cancer so to recap cancer
freezing cold and if you're not killed
in the blasts you starve to death
cheery well at least the Fallout games
take place a couple of hundred years
after the great war so the planet was
well on its way to fixing itself and
there's the Handy Garden of Eden
creation kids to give it a bit of a
helping hand to how humans survived by
keeping themselves locked up in a vault
tech fallout shelter of course for the
purpose of this video at least let's
assume you're not subject to any of
alt-text
experiments and are just surviving in a
vault until the world outside is safe
enough to inhabit food water fake
sunlight have all been taken care of but
how would you fare if you'd lived
indoors for your entire life and was
suddenly allowed to go outside well in
keeping with this episode's cheery theme
probably not that well reports from
Arctic expeditions and submarine crews
show that groups locked up for an
extended period of time tend to suffer
from
and anxiety but it's not known how long
the isolation will last but I really
likely to suffer from depression it's
also known that without sufficient
stimuli the brain sort of Withers
this was shown in an awful case where
children from a Romanian orphanage were
left with no stimuli for years and when
they were found they couldn't even focus
their eyes because of years of their
brains being under stimulated with that
in mind in the Fallout games those who
have come from vaults are more likely to
suffer from agoraphobia which is a fear
of open spaces and xenophobia a fear of
other people amongst other issues so if
you're not incinerated or irradiated by
the bombs and you managed to survive
years of constant hunger and frigid
cave-dwelling you can look forward to
human society being resurrected by
stunted mold people with the loosest
grasp about what human society even is
so fingers crossed it never happens in
real life then thanks for watching guys
dumped again you can find me on Twitter
at Lucy James games and I'll see you
next time for some more reality check